hi I'm Evan Carmichael I'm welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question for
one of our readers Joey who asks hey
Evan I want to know your opinion on
penny auction sites I know this business
model is quite big in the US and Europe
do you think it will work in Asia Joey
so Joey I'm going to give you an answer
that maybe is not what you want to hear
but I've never been a big fan of
businesses that are just trying to make
a quick buck I've always tried to
encourage entrepreneurs and follow
something they're really passionate
about and something that they can add a
lot of value to and help people up with
because those are the businesses that
you're going to have long-term success
with a lot of entrepreneurs start a
business try to make you know quick bot
trying to get rich quick and usually the
exact opposite happens and is the reason
why most businesses fail a lot of this
cuz they're they're chasing you know
that quick money and they're not
actually doing something that adds a lot
of value so if you're thinking long-term
value that you can add you're going to
be compensated in proportion to how much
value and how much help you can give to
your target customers so I would try to
encourage you to look at something
you're super passionate about something
you think you can really help people out
and it could still be in the online
space and try to focus all your energies
on that as much as you can and is useful
and helpful as possible and from there
you'll be able to develop your business
model and at the end of they make a lot
of money instead of trying to you know
chase that quick buck if you look at the
famous entrepreneur profiles that we've
had all across our site almost all of
them started because they had a strong
intense passion to you know make that
industry better than it was before you
never see them starting off saying i won
i want to get rich and usually when you
you know try to get rich it doesn't
happen but if you try to add a lot of
value then you'll get all the riches
that you're you're after so maybe not
the answer you're looking for but i hope
that gives you some perspective if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below I'd also love to hear
thoughts if you want to leave
comment and stay tuned for the next
episode
you